Hey, Will. Hello there. Hey, Sean. Will, you got some real sweaty pits today. Are you concerned about anything? Are you nervous? I am nervous. I just took a lie detector. Oh, wow. And what was the result? I'm a liar. Anyway, this episode is going to be great. Yeah, we're going to work out some truth. Yeah, it's an all new Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart.
嘿，威尔。你好啊。嘿，肖恩。威尔，你今天腋下出汗很严重啊。你在担心什么吗？你紧张吗？我很紧张。我刚做了测谎仪测试。哦，哇。结果怎么样？我是个骗子。不管怎样，这一集会很棒。是的，我们要理清一些真相。是的，这是一个全新的《Smartless》。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic.
Less。Smart。Less。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。
Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic. Hot mic, hot mics, hot mics. Hi, hot mics. Hey, hi, hot mics. Hot mics. Send us pics of all your hot mics. Post them on our page.
麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关。麦克风没关，麦克风没关，麦克风没关。嗨，麦克风没关。嘿，嗨，麦克风没关。麦克风没关。把你们麦克风没关的照片发给我们。发到我们的主页上。
We'd love to take a look at all your hot mics. He's so tired, he's still got it. So tired, still got it. Sean, you had a hot bob once, didn't you? I had a hot toddy, a hot bob and a hot mic. You ever had a hot bob haircut? Yeah you did on the, whatchamacallit, Stooge's film. I had that shelf haircut in the 80s
我们很想看看你们所有麦克风没关的情况。他太累了，但他依然宝刀未老。太累了，依然宝刀未老。肖恩，你以前留过那种很火的波波头，对吧？我喝过热托迪，留过热波波头，还有麦克风没关。你留过那种很火的波波头吗？是的，你在那个，叫什么来着，那个《三个臭皮匠》的电影里留过。我在80年代留过那种架子头。
where you cut it from the back. Did you really? Yeah. That sounds very Depeche Mode. It's T? Yeah. That sounds very Depeche Mode. It's total, it's TDM, total Depeche Mode. I had like kind of long and then it's short in the back. Ew, you had it like covering one of your eyes? Yeah, just kind of like coming up, you know.
就是从后面剪短的那种。你真的留过？是啊。那听起来很像赶时髦合唱团（Depeche Mode）。是T吗？是啊。那听起来很像赶时髦合唱团。完全是，是TDM，完全是赶时髦合唱团。我留得有点长，然后后面剪短了。呃，你留那种遮住一只眼睛的发型？是啊，就是那种向上翘的感觉，你知道的。
Archie's kind of got that, right? You're all the sun there, listener. He's got a little bit of a what's that? Kind of looking through his hair. Now it's kind of long all around. What's that? That's a what's that, kind of looking through his hair. Now it's kind of long all around. What's that? That's a what's that haircut? What's that?
阿奇（Archie）留的就是那种，对吧？听众朋友们，你们都在那儿呢。他有点那个，叫什么来着？透过头发看东西。现在四周都留长了。那是什么？那是，那是，透过头发看东西。现在四周都留长了。那是什么？那是，那是种什么发型？那是什么？
Yeah, I can't hear you because my hair is blocking my eyes, not my ears. Richard Ehrlich, the last thing he says to himself before he leaves, what's that? Yeah, yeah, our buddy, the most incredible real estate broker in the world. He is so good. If you're looking to buy a home in Los Angeles area.
是啊，我听不见你说话，因为我的头发挡住了我的眼睛，而不是耳朵。理查德·埃利希（Richard Ehrlich），他离开前对自己说的最后一句话，那是什么？是啊，是啊，我们的好哥们，世界上最不可思议的房地产经纪人。他太棒了。如果你想在洛杉矶地区买房。
Especially in the west side of Los Angeles area. Tricky Dicky Ricky Ehrlich. Richard Ehrlich is your guy. Yeah, he's amazing. And he's also an OG super fan of Smart Lips. Yes, so hello to Richard if you're listening. Richard's got a, Richard's got, I may have bored you with this before,
特别是在洛杉矶西区。狡猾的迪基·瑞奇·埃利希。理查德·埃利希就是你要找的人。是啊，他太棒了。而且他还是《Smartless》的骨灰级超级粉丝。是的，所以如果理查德在听的话，向他问好。理查德有个，理查德有个，我可能之前跟你唠叨过，
he's got a mirror face like we all do, but he's got a trigger sentence that launches that mirror face. You know, everyone's got a face that they use. What's a mirror face? Well, when you look in the mirror, when you wanna look your best, like one last look to go out,
他有个“镜子脸”，就像我们所有人一样，但他有个触发句子能启动那个镜子脸。你知道，每个人都有一个他们会用的表情。什么是镜子脸？嗯，当你照镜子时，当你想要展现最好的一面时，比如出门前最后看一眼，
you kinda tighten up the eyes, you maybe turn your head a little bit. Well, Fon's had a, right? Like that was exactly, right. The mirror face, okay. So what Richard does to prompt the mirror look he's looking for is he pretends that he is asking someone for directions, right?
你会稍微收紧眼睛，也许稍微转一下头。嗯，冯（Fon）有过，对吧？就像那样，没错。镜子脸，好吧。所以理查德为了做出他想要的镜子表情，他会假装自己在向别人问路，对吧？
He's pulled up in his car next to someone walking their dog maybe, and he asks them directions, and they give them the directions, and he looks forward over a steering wheel, and then he figures, well, maybe I didn't hear it correctly, and then he'll turn to his left, to the person, and he'll go, it's where? And so it's where, the combination of the turn
他把车停在路边，旁边可能有人在遛狗，他问他们路，他们告诉他怎么走，他透过方向盘向前看，然后他想，嗯，也许我没听清楚，然后他会转向左边，对着那个人，说，是在哪儿？所以是在哪儿，转头和提问的结合
and the question will tighten up the eyes just enough and give him just enough disdain to look sexy. It's where? Yeah, that's a good red carpet photo. Sexy disdain, that's the new one, right? Yeah, he never looks hotter than when he says it's wear. Which is so crazy because he's such a nice guy. He's a nice guy and he's nice looking,
会把眼睛收紧到恰到好处，并给他足够的轻蔑感，看起来很性感。是在哪儿？是啊，那是一张很好的红毯照片。性感的轻蔑，这是新招，对吧？是啊，他说“是在哪儿”的时候看起来最性感。这太疯狂了，因为他是个这么好的人。他是个好人，长得也好看，
but he just is not good with directions. Sean, good morning. Good morning to you. What have you done so far today aside from putting on some smartless swag, I see there on your body? You know, he's always wearing smartless shit, Will. Like we're televising this and he's helping move merchandise. I wear it because I really like it.
但他就是不擅长认路。肖恩，早上好。早上好。除了穿上一些《Smartless》的周边，我看到你身上穿的，你今天还做了什么？你知道，他总是穿着《Smartless》的衣服，威尔。就像我们在电视直播一样，他在帮忙推销商品。我穿是因为我真的很喜欢。
I sleep in it. He sleeps in it. And Sean, what was the sleep schedule last night? Cause you have a weird, you wake up at the night and then you go back to bed early in the morning. I go to bed at about midnight. I get up at about 3 a.m., I stay up until about six or seven,
我穿着它睡觉。他穿着它睡觉。肖恩，昨晚的睡眠时间表是怎样的？因为你很奇怪，你会在半夜醒来，然后清晨又回去睡觉。我大约午夜睡觉。我大约凌晨3点起床，一直待到六七点，
then I fall back asleep for a couple hours, and I'm good to go. And then I need like a 10 minute nap. And then I'm good to go. Total chaos, and then I'm good to go. It is total chaos. I'll send emails at three or four in the morning. I know, oh I know. Oh, I know.
然后我再回去睡几个小时，我就精神了。然后我需要大约10分钟的小睡。然后我就精神了。完全是一团糟，然后我就精神了。这简直是一团糟。我会在凌晨三四点发邮件。我知道，哦，我知道。哦，我知道。
Oh, I know. Don't start doing Will. By the way, I love the way your impression of me just has the dumbest look on your face. Oh, I know. You know what we've done here, Sean, though? We've boosted up young Willie. Willie started this, started the pod a little bit down,
哦，我知道。别开始学我，威尔。顺便说一句，我喜欢你模仿我时脸上那种愚蠢的表情。哦，我知道。你知道我们在这里做了什么吗，肖恩？我们给年轻的威利（Willie）打气了。威利刚开始的时候，刚开始录播客时有点低落，
a little bit out of sorts, and then there's just a little bit of love. And now the wings are flapping. All right, tighten up, guests, here we come. Today, we have a guest who's a giant in many categories. She's a titan in music, acting, producing, philanthropy, business, and social media. If you wanted to describe a person who's uniquely suited
有点心不在焉，然后就得到了一点爱。现在翅膀扇动起来了。好了，打起精神来，嘉宾们，我们来了。今天，我们有一位在多个领域都是巨人的嘉宾。她是音乐、表演、制作、慈善、商业和社交媒体领域的泰坦。如果你想描述一个独特地适合
to soar in today's media and cultural systems, you would simply say her name. I think I know who this is. She's a Grammy, Emmy, SAG, Golden Globe, and Critics Choice Nominated musician, actress, and producer. Her music has amassed 34 billion streams globally. She's got a movie coming out, a TV show that's already on,
在当今媒体和文化体系中翱翔的人，你只需说出她的名字。我想我知道这是谁了。她是格莱美、艾美奖、演员工会奖、金球奖和评论家选择奖提名的音乐家、演员和制片人。她的音乐在全球积累了340亿次流媒体播放量。她有一部电影要上映，一部正在播出的电视剧，
and a company that exceeds 300 million in sales annually. And when she's not running those things, she's keeping up with her 428 million followers on Instagram. What else needs to be said, guys? Please welcome the lazy, unaccomplished, unmotivated, and perpetually failing Miss Selena Gomez. Woohoo! Woo hoo! Oh boy. I'm motivated.
还有一家年销售额超过3亿的公司。当她不忙于这些事情时，她还在Instagram上跟进她的4.28亿粉丝。还需要说什么吗，伙计们？请欢迎这位懒惰、一事无成、缺乏动力且不断失败的赛琳娜·戈麦斯（Selena Gomez）小姐。呜呼！呜呼！天哪。我有动力。
I'm motivated, perpetually failing. It was so hard not to laugh, it was so hard. Oh my gosh, Selena, hello. Hi. Hi guys, I'm so happy to be here. I'm so happy you're here. This is a very nice thing you're doing for us and our listeners.
我有动力，不断失败。忍住不笑太难了，太难了。天哪，赛琳娜，你好。嗨。嗨，伙计们，我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴你来了。你为我们和我们的听众做了一件非常好的事情。
Oh no, this is more my thing, I'm so happy. It here. This is a very nice thing you're doing for us and our listeners. Oh no, this is more my thing. I'm so happy. It's pretty cool of you. If we didn't know, it looks like you were lying in bed in sheets. We have an overhand shot. Yes, well that is my beautiful background that I made for you guys,
哦不，这更像是我的事，我很高兴。在这里。你为我们和我们的听众做了一件非常好的事情。哦不，这更像是我的事。我很高兴。你真是太酷了。如果我们不知道的话，看起来你正躺在床上的床单里。我们有一个俯拍镜头。是的，嗯，那是我为你们制作的美丽背景，
because I figured that would be better than random. You're keeping it real. Listeners, she's got just a sheet draped over just a bunch of dead bodies behind you Good work. Thanks. Yeah, I'm a segue into murders So, oh, yeah. Well, we're gonna get to that. We're gonna get to that. So Selena Where do we find you this morning? Are you in Los Angeles? I am I am home right now And I just had my coffee and yep. What time do you usually get up every morning?
因为我觉得这比随机的背景要好。你保持真实。听众们，她身后只是一块床单盖着一堆尸体。干得好。谢谢。是啊，我要过渡到谋杀案了。所以，哦，是的。好吧，我们会谈到那个的。我们会谈到那个的。那么赛琳娜，今天早上我们在哪里找到你？你在洛杉矶吗？我在，我现在在家。我刚喝了咖啡，是的。你通常每天早上几点起床？
I'm a 6.30 guy. I'm about seven, 7.30. Are there animals to feed? Yes, I have two dogs. You do? What kind? They're little multi-poos. They're pretty annoying but cute.
我是6点30分起床的人。我大约七点，七点半。有动物要喂吗？是的，我有两只狗。你有？什么品种？它们是小马尔济斯贵宾犬（Malty-poos）。它们很烦人但很可爱。
Two the same. Is that because your body gets you up at seven or are you just like me? No, my body does. I think, I don't know, for some reason, maybe the show or something, it's just embedded in me that I'm automatically up and then I feel like a piece of shit if I wake up at like ten.
两只一样的。是因为你的身体让你七点起床，还是你就像我一样？不，是我的身体。我想，我不知道，出于某种原因，也许是节目什么的，它已经植入我体内了，我会自动起床，如果我睡到十点，我会觉得自己像坨屎。
Sure. Even though those are nice. What is that about the body that will just wake you up at the same time every single day? Circadian rhythm. Wurveling at the body. Look at this guy. Yeah. And then if you just point it,
当然。尽管那样很舒服。身体每天在同一时间叫醒你，这是怎么回事？昼夜节律。对身体大惊小怪。看看这家伙。是啊。然后如果你只是指着它，
and then if you point your eyes at something, it tells your brain what you're seeing. Uh-huh. A miracle. It's just a miracle. It's so much discovery. You're like a one man Spielberg movie. Just a wonderment of discovery.
然后如果你把眼睛指向某样东西，它就会告诉你的大脑你看到了什么。嗯哼。一个奇迹。这简直是个奇迹。有太多的发现了。你就像一部斯皮尔伯格电影里的独角戏。简直是发现的奇迹。
Guys, if you put one foot in front of another, you'll just end up moving forward. That's incredible. All right, so Celia, with these two dogs, they're Maltese, Malty Poo's. Yes. So that's a combo, right? Yes, they're very cute.
伙计们，如果你迈出一只脚，你最终就会向前移动。这太不可思议了。好了，那么赛琳娜，这两只狗，它们是马尔济斯，马尔济斯贵宾犬。是的。所以那是一个组合，对吧？是的，它们非常可爱。
They're brother and sister? No, they are, I got them at two different times, but they definitely don't act like brother and sister. No. Rescue's Pure Breads, we can cut that if you want. No, no, no. I actually am not afraid to say, during COVID I was very scared and lonely
它们是兄妹吗？不，它们是，我是分两次得到的，但它们绝对不像兄妹。不。救援纯种狗，如果你想的话我们可以剪掉。不，不，不。其实我不怕说，在新冠期间我非常害怕和孤独，
and I found one on Craigslist because the mom was like, we had babies and we don't know what to do. Yes, they were like, we don't know what to do, our dog had puppies like, we don't know what to do our dog had puppies So I was like, I'll take one clear out for a joke. Go ahead. Well, no Though they like drove in from Vegas and like rolled the window halfway down and passed me the dog and wanted the cash I was like, all right my my I did have a bad experience. I did have a bad experience one
我在Craigslist上找到了一个，因为那个妈妈说，我们生了宝宝，不知道该怎么办。是的，他们就像，我们不知道该怎么办，我们的狗生了小狗，我们不知道该怎么办。所以我说，我会带走一只。开个玩笑。继续。好吧，不，他们是从拉斯维加斯开车过来的，把车窗摇下一半，把狗递给我，然后要现金。我说，好吧，我确实有过一次糟糕的经历。我确实有过一次糟糕的经历。
Here we go. I posted on Craigslist. Yeah said, who wants, for a hundred bucks you wanna come out and check out these puppies? And let me say, when I got to his house, it was not. Dogs. A dog. It was not dogs. Come check out these puppies for a hundred bucks.
开始了。我在Craigslist上发了帖子。是啊，说，谁想要，花一百块钱你想出来看看这些小狗吗？让我说，当我到他家时，不是。狗。一只狗。不是狗。花一百块钱来看看这些小狗。
Thank you, Will. Thank you, you rest again. All right, let's. Will. Thank you. You rest again. Um, alright, um, let's... Will's having a literal spintank in his own mouth. Um, we're a little sloppy this morning. We are super sloppy. Selena, isn't it better to get this over with than in the afternoon? No, I actually don't mind this. This is a great way to start my day.
谢谢，威尔。谢谢，你又休息了。好了，让我们。威尔。谢谢。你又休息了。嗯，好了，嗯，让我们……威尔嘴里简直在喷水。嗯，我们今天早上有点草率。我们超级草率。赛琳娜，把这事在下午之前解决掉不是更好吗？不，我其实不介意。这是开始我一天的好方法。
You guys are making me laugh. Well, keep your knees bent. It's not over yet. We'll let you revisit that at the end to see if you still love it. All right, now Selena, you're incredibly accomplished. You started very young. I wanna know, so you started with acting, yes,
你们让我笑了。好吧，保持膝盖弯曲。还没结束呢。我们最后会让你重温一下，看看你是否还喜欢它。好了，现在赛琳娜，你成就斐然。你很小就开始了。我想知道，所以你是从表演开始的，是的，
because mom was an actor and got you kind of interested in that, question mark? Yeah, she actually never pressured me or said that's what I should do. She just did a lot of theater growing up, so she never really did anything television-wise. And I was seven when I got my first job because I was only child, super dramatic, and I was like, I got my first job because I was only child, super dramatic,
因为妈妈是演员，让你对那个感兴趣，问号？是啊，她其实从来没有给我压力，也没有说那是我应该做的。她成长过程中做了很多戏剧表演，所以她从来没有真正做过电视方面的工作。我七岁时得到了第一份工作，因为我是独生女，超级戏剧化，我当时说，我得到了第一份工作，因为我是独生女，超级戏剧化，
and I was like, I'm so capable of this. And I did- Kind of all it takes. Yeah, it's true. But it worked, and I've just been working ever since, and I feel really lucky. Was this Barney? That was Barney, the purple guy.
我当时说，我完全有能力做到这一点。我做了——这差不多就是全部了。是啊，是真的。但它奏效了，从那以后我就一直在工作，我觉得自己真的很幸运。这是《巴尼与朋友》（Barney）吗？那是《巴尼》，那个紫色的家伙。
Oh, that's crazy. You were in Barney? Started with Barney. Yes. That's amazing. That's pretty rad. The guy who played Barney, he was pretty hot. Was he? Yeah, he was hot. He had to be fit and cute because he was in this.
哦，那太疯狂了。你演过《巴尼》？从《巴尼》开始。是的。那太神奇了。那很酷。演巴尼的那个家伙，他挺帅的。是吗？是啊，他很帅。他必须身材好又可爱，因为他在这个里面。
No way. Hot Barney. This is changing everything. That's a new doc. So he was a plushie. Yeah. I'm sorry, Sean. Just quick for Tracy really quick. Does Tracy need to know this? Does she want to know what a plushie is? I thought she's like a fetish where people dress up in like costumes and stuff, right? No, I heard no
没门。帅气的巴尼。这改变了一切。那是一部新纪录片。所以他是个毛绒玩具。是啊。对不起，肖恩。快速问一下特蕾西（Tracy）。特蕾西需要知道这个吗？她想知道什么是毛绒玩具吗？我以为那是一种恋物癖，人们打扮成服装之类的，对吧？不，我听说不。
Yes, what do you mean? Right? Thank you. You don't need to say right question mark to us Yeah, we're gonna air something or something or that is correct John Alright so we're with Barney and we're having fun on that and then how did that happen? I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie.
是的，你是什么意思？对吧？谢谢。你不需要对我们说“对吧”问号。是的，我们要播出什么东西或者那是什么，那是正确的，约翰。好了，所以我们和巴尼在一起，我们在那上面玩得很开心，然后那是怎么发生的？我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。
I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie.
我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。
I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna cool to be on TV. Yeah, I mean my mom wasn't very intense about what I could watch. So I would stay up and watch Friends with her and Will and Grace. And that was like what I grew up with. Barney and Will and Grace. For the longest time by the way on my bio on Instagram says, I love Will and Grace.
我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。我不会撒谎，我不会撒谎。上电视很酷。是啊，我的意思是我的妈妈对我可以看什么并不太在意。所以我经常熬夜和她一起看《老友记》和《威尔和格蕾丝》。那是我成长过程中看的东西。巴尼和《威尔和格蕾丝》。顺便说一句，很长一段时间以来，我的Instagram简介上写着，我爱《威尔和格蕾丝》。
No way. That's so sweet. For like a solid year and then everyone was like, can you maybe change that?. No way. That's so sweet. Yeah, for like a solid year, and then everyone was like, can you maybe change that? I was like, That's very sweet. Did you ever see the episode where Will was in a dance off with Sean?
没门。那太甜了。大概有一整年，然后每个人都说，你能不能换一下？没门。那太甜了。是啊，大概有一整年，然后每个人都说，你能不能换一下？我说，那很甜。你看过威尔和肖恩跳舞比赛的那一集吗？
With Janet Jackson. With Janet Jackson? You did? I was a backup dancer. I played a backup dancer. Oh, that's right, and then Karen got mad because she fell for you, And yes, I remember. Yes. Oh my God. You really are a fan.
和珍妮·杰克逊（Janet Jackson）一起。和珍妮·杰克逊？你看了？我是伴舞。我演了一个伴舞。哦，对了，然后凯伦（Karen）生气了，因为她爱上了你，是的，我记得。是的。天哪。你真的是个粉丝。
Wait, Will, I remember you snapping those moves. I think I was there that night, right? You were there that night. You really know how to finish a move. Remember how hard we played before? But we're so tired and Jimmy's like, okay, let's do it again. I looked at Sean and I'm like, we're going to do it again. But Selena, do you know just as a Will and Grace superfan, you know that there's a podcast that Sean does
等等，威尔，我记得你跳那些动作。我想那天晚上我在场，对吧？那天晚上你在场。你真的很会完成一个动作。还记得我们之前玩得有多开心吗？但我们太累了，吉米（Jimmy）说，好吧，我们再来一次。我看着肖恩，我说，我们要再来一次。但赛琳娜，作为一个《威尔和格蕾丝》的超级粉丝，你知道肖恩有一个播客吗？
called Just Jack and Will that he does with Eric McCormack. No, I do know. I actually do know. And I remember my friend sent me the link because she knew that I was obsessed and I had no idea. No way. Yeah. Sean, did you know that Selena Gomez
叫《Just Jack and Will》，他和埃里克·麦柯马克（Eric McCormack）一起做的。不，我知道。我确实知道。我记得我朋友把链接发给我，因为她知道我着迷了，我完全不知道。没门。是啊。肖恩，你知道赛琳娜·戈麦斯
was such a huge Will and Grace fan? I did because I'm really good friends with Marty short Oh, and then we chatted on the phone me and Selena chatted on the phone like a year ago or something and you were like Oh my god, and I was like, oh my god No likewise No, I'm very I'm very excited I With you so me too and I grew up with you, so. Me too, and I grew up with you. Now. 53, 53 years.
是《威尔和格蕾丝》的超级粉丝吗？我知道，因为我和马丁·肖特（Marty Short）是好朋友。哦，然后我们在电话里聊过，我和赛琳娜大概一年前在电话里聊过，你说，哦，天哪，我说，哦，天哪。同样。不，我很兴奋，我和你在一起，所以我也一样。我从小看你的戏长大。我也一样，我从小看你的戏长大。现在。53岁，53岁。
All right, so we're galloping along with acting. We've got the Barney under our belts. We'll move into Waverly Place. Yes, my Disney show. Yes, and a few other jobs here and in there, and things are really moving. And cooking. And then there's a cooking show later, we're gonna get to that.
好了，我们继续谈表演。我们有《巴尼》的经验。我们进入《少年魔法师》（Waverly Place）。是的，我的迪士尼节目。是的，还有其他一些工作，事情进展得很顺利。还有烹饪。稍后还有一个烹饪节目，我们会谈到那个。
But when did music start to tap you on the shoulder and say, hey, come this way? Well, I think that Disney is safe to say they're a machine, and they kind of, in a a way not forcefully required that I know how to sing so I could sing like the theme song like they know how to package someone and like make it like a whole triple threat thing. This was happening during Waverly? Yeah.
但是音乐是什么时候开始拍你的肩膀说，嘿，往这边走？嗯，我认为迪士尼可以肯定地说他们是一台机器，他们以一种并非强迫的方式要求我知道如何唱歌，这样我就可以唱主题曲，就像他们知道如何包装一个人，让它成为一个全能的三栖明星。这发生在《少年魔法师》期间？是啊。
So they asked me to do the theme song and I had fun with that and then they were like, would you like to do the theme song and I had fun with that and then they were like, would you like to do an album? I thought it would be fun and I thought more than anything it would be like a hobby that I really enjoyed. And then I wanted to be a serious actress. I was 15. And I wanted to be an actress. I never really intended on being a singer full time
所以他们让我唱主题曲，我玩得很开心，然后他们说，你想唱主题曲吗？我玩得很开心，然后他们说，你想出一张专辑吗？我觉得那会很有趣，而且我觉得最重要的是，那会是我真正喜欢的爱好。然后我想成为一名严肃的演员。我当时15岁。我想成为一名演员。我从来没打算全职做歌手，
but apparently that hobby turned into something else. Now, did you have any idea that you could sing before you tried it? Yeah, well I was on Barney and I did do, I love you. You love me. Wow, that's not very challenging. And you know, it warmed up my vocals.
但显然那个爱好变成了别的东西。那么，在你尝试之前，你知道你能唱歌吗？是啊，我在《巴尼》里，我确实唱了，“我爱你，你爱我”。哇，那不太有挑战性。而且你知道，它热了我的嗓子。
Okay, all right. There you go. And then because of that, did you take singing lessons and develop your instrument, as they say? You know, I did. I don't think I'm the best singer, but I think I know how to tell stories, and I love being able to make songs that,
好吧，好吧。就是这样。然后因为那个，你上过声乐课并发展了你的乐器，正如他们所说的那样吗？你知道，我上了。我不认为我是最好的歌手，但我认为我知道如何讲故事，我喜欢能够制作歌曲，
you know, I get more, like, I always get people coming up to me saying, I had no idea it was you that was singing that song, and that kind of makes it feel nice. It makes, to me saying, I had no idea it was you that was singing that song. And that kind of makes it feel nice. It makes it to me that I feel like it's just about the song then. I mean, Wizards of Waverly Place was a gigantic hit show. Yeah, I miss it.
你知道，我得到更多，就像，我总是有人走过来对我说，我不知道那首歌是你唱的，这让人感觉很好。它让，对我来说，我不知道那首歌是你唱的。这让人感觉很好。它让，对我来说，我觉得那只是关于歌曲本身。我的意思是，《少年魔法师》是一个巨大的热门节目。是啊，我很怀念它。
I wanna say my sister wrote on that for a second. Really? She was a writer on that maybe. I might not be remembering. But it was a blast. Like I will say yes. That's why I love sitcoms. Would you say you have a good memory, Jason?
我想说我姐姐在那上面写过一会儿剧本。真的吗？她可能是那里的编剧。我可能记不清了。但那是一次爆炸。就像我会说是的。这就是为什么我喜欢情景喜剧。你觉得你的记忆力好吗，杰森？
No, not really. Okay. Wayne, we're going to get right back to you. But Selena, I want to... It's Will, actually. So, what is it? It's Will. Thank you, Scott.
不，不太好。好吧。韦恩，我们马上回来找你。但赛琳娜，我想……其实是威尔。所以，是什么？是威尔。谢谢，斯科特。
So... Oh my gosh, the bits. I love the bits. I love the bits. I love it. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. All right, so then you know that you can kind of sing a little bit and the music starts to take off.
所以……天哪，这些梗。我喜欢这些梗。我喜欢这些梗。我喜欢它。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。好了，所以你知道你可以唱一点点，音乐开始起飞了。
Like, I guess what I'm asking is at what point was the acting and the music at the same level, and you thought, do I have to pick, or should I try to keep both these things going at the same speed? I started having a lot of fun with music, and then touring was really fun. But I was doing my TV show at the same time. Wizards, and I just, I found it wizards, and I just,
就像，我想问的是，在什么阶段表演和音乐处于同一水平，你认为，我必须做出选择吗，还是我应该尝试让这两件事以同样的速度进行？我开始从音乐中获得很多乐趣，然后巡演真的很有趣。但我同时在做我的电视节目。《少年魔法师》，我只是，我发现《少年魔法师》，我只是，
I found it really fun, so I just kept going, but the older I get, the more I'm kinda like, I would like to find something to just settle on. Yeah. Well, it's exhausting, right? I mean, that sounds like super, that's so hard. I just think about the energy, this is such an old game. Oh my God, I went to a mental institute
我发现它真的很有趣，所以我一直坚持下去，但随着年龄的增长，我越来越觉得，我想找点什么来安定下来。是啊。嗯，这很累人，对吧？我的意思是，这听起来超级，这太难了。我只是想到能量，这真是一个古老的游戏。天哪，我去了精神病院，
and canceled one of my tours, like, ooh. Really? Because of too much work. It was so exhausting. Yeah, it just got to me, because I love working and it distracts me from bad things and I like that, so I just like working. I was just saying that this morning.
取消了我的巡演之一，就像，噢。真的吗？因为工作太多了。太累人了。是啊，它只是影响了我，因为我喜欢工作，它让我从坏事中分心，我喜欢那样，所以我只是喜欢工作。我今天早上刚说过。
By the way, it reminds me, my three-year-old Denny, he calls lizards, because he can't say El, he calls them wizards. So he's always like, there's a wizard in the backyard. I hope he's right. I really hope there's a wizard in the backyard. Because I don't want to talk to him. But wait, but Selena, you're saying that in a perfect world you would pick either one or the other going forward Well, I do feel like I have one more album in me, but I would I would probably choose acting you would yes
顺便说一句，这让我想起，我三岁的丹尼（Denny），他把蜥蜴（lizards）叫成巫师（wizards），因为他不会发L的音。所以他总是说，后院里有个巫师。我希望他是对的。我真的希望后院里有个巫师。因为我不想和他说话。但是等等，但是赛琳娜，你是说在完美的世界里，你会选择其中一个或另一个继续前进？嗯，我确实觉得我还有一张专辑，但我可能会选择表演。你会吗？是的。
Damn, you're so great at music though Yeah, yeah, I mean here's the good news you don't have to pick don't have to pick you right But I am gonna want to chill cuz I'm tired. Mm-, I mean, reading through, I can tell you, we've had some very accomplished people on this show. Thank you listeners for making it a place where accomplished people want to come. I have never read so much information about a guest than I have about you.
该死，你在音乐方面也很棒。是啊，是啊，我的意思是好消息是你不需要选择，不需要选择，你对吧。但我会想要放松，因为我累了。嗯，我的意思是，读完这些，我可以告诉你，我们在这个节目上有一些非常有成就的人。感谢听众让这里成为有成就的人想来的地方。我从来没有读过关于嘉宾的这么多信息，就像我读到关于你的一样。
I mean, the things you have done in your, I mean, you're just barely 30, aren't you? 31. It's just so admirable what you've done. Thank you. It's mind blowing. In philanthropy and in global sort of charities and being in, what, a UNICEF ambassador?
我的意思是，你在你的，我的意思是，你才刚满30岁，不是吗？31岁。你所做的一切真是令人钦佩。谢谢。这太令人震惊了。在慈善事业和全球慈善机构中，作为，什么，联合国儿童基金会大使？
I was a UNICEF ambassador and now I have my own foundation. Yeah, it's just stunning. And we haven't even gotten to Rare Beauty, this beauty company, the makeup company, what do you call it? Rare Beauty. Yeah, but I mean what would you describe it as, a beauty company? Yeah, I would say cosmetics.
我曾是联合国儿童基金会大使，现在我有自己的基金会。是啊，这太令人惊叹了。我们甚至还没谈到Rare Beauty，这个美容公司，化妆品公司，你叫它什么？Rare Beauty。是啊，但我的意思是你会怎么描述它，一家美容公司？是啊，我会说是化妆品。
It's been really fun but we're actually starting to get into skin now. I know this is all girly stuff, but I'm excited. It's definitely. I'm wearing makeup right now. Yeah, exactly. I know, but we're going into skin now. It's about three years old,
这真的很有趣，但我们实际上现在开始进入护肤领域了。我知道这都是女孩子的东西，但我很兴奋。这绝对是。我现在正戴着化妆品。是啊，没错。我知道，但我们现在要进入护肤领域了。它大概三岁了，
and it's honestly been the biggest gift, because I launched it during COVID, and it just took off, and I couldn't be more thankful. Did you launch it during COVID and it just took off and I couldn't be more thankful. Did you launch it during COVID because you had time to finally, because you weren't on tour and you weren't shooting, you're like, now I have time to dedicate to this?
这真的是最大的礼物，因为我在新冠期间推出了它，它就起飞了，我再感激不过了。你在新冠期间推出了它，它就起飞了，我再感激不过了。你在新冠期间推出它是因为你终于有时间了，因为你没有巡演，也没有拍摄，你就像，现在我有时间致力于这个了？
Or it kind of came up or was it something you always? It sucked. I was supposed to release it like a month right into COVID. So I had done all the promotion and everything. It's about to come out. And then we figured, all right, we'll just try online. And I think makeup became really big during COVID because people would do the videos
还是它自然而然地出现了，还是你一直都想？它糟透了。我本应该在新冠刚开始一个月左右发布它。所以我做了所有的宣传和一切。它快要出来了。然后我们想，好吧，我们就在网上试试。而且我认为化妆品在新冠期间变得非常大，因为人们会制作视频，
and they would create looks. And it kind of just took off. And I'm always confused and just grateful because I've never been the type of person that want, I don't want to be or need to be the number one anything. And I think that's what my mom has instilled in me because I don't feel like anything's a competition. So I feel like there's room for everyone.
他们会创造造型。它就那样起飞了。我总是很困惑，只是感激，因为我从来不是那种想要，我不想成为或需要成为第一的人。我认为这就是我妈妈灌输给我的，因为我不觉得任何事情都是竞争。所以我觉得每个人都有空间。
So I'm really proud. Do you think like, when you started Barney at seven and then Wizards and then all that, do you think that your work ethic and your drive and your ambition was instilled in you or would have happened to any way? Oh, I don't know. I probably would have been a hot mess
所以我真的很自豪。你认为，当你七岁开始《巴尼》时，然后是《少年魔法师》，然后所有这些，你认为你的职业道德、动力和野心是灌输给你的，还是无论如何都会发生？哦，我不知道。我可能已经是一团糟了，
if I wasn't doing this, I already am. But I don't know, I don't know. We are all hot. Obviously tell us how. Oh, I've been to like four treatment centers and woo. Just because of depression and anxiety, right? Yeah, yeah, and I'm bipolar as well. Carry on top.
如果我不做这个的话，我已经是一团糟了。但我不知道，我不知道。我们都是热的。显然告诉我们怎么做。哦，我去过大约四个治疗中心，呜。只是因为抑郁和焦虑，对吧？是啊，是啊，而且我也有双相情感障碍。继续。
I would say you've got an incredible dynamic head on your shoulders that takes a lot of management and analysis and it sounds like you're doing a pretty fricking good job. Yeah, no kidding. Thank you. I don't know, Disney was like boot camp. They were definitely.
我会说你有一个令人难以置信的动态头脑，需要大量的管理和分析，听起来你做得非常棒。是啊，没开玩笑。谢谢。我不知道，迪士尼就像训练营。他们绝对是。
You know who doesn't have problems? You know who doesn't have problems, Lena? Dummies. You know, I mean, that's where you get that blissful ignorance, that's where it comes from. You need to be really smart to be complicated. Yeah, and I'm pretty, I don't know. I can be a little.
你知道谁没有问题吗？你知道谁没有问题，莉娜？傻瓜。你知道，我的意思是，这就是那种幸福的无知，这就是它的来源。你需要非常聪明才能变得复杂。是啊，而且我很，我不知道。我可以有点。
Yeah, I think you're doing great. It's not getting in your way of your accomplishments, and you and I have talked a few times. You're incredibly nice, so your personal success is fantastic as well as opposed to your business success. So whatever you're doing, keep going. Yeah. Are you super excited?
是啊，我觉得你做得很好。它没有阻碍你的成就，你和我谈过几次。你非常友善，所以你的个人成功和你的商业成功一样精彩。所以无论你在做什么，继续前进。是啊。你超级兴奋吗？
So your mom, as you said, your mom is or was an actress and kind of that sort of paved the way for you to get into it and take it seriously. And you mentioned you're an only child. Imagine you're still pretty close with your folks. Yes. And was that like, when you started to make that transition into becoming a star at a really young age,
所以你的妈妈，正如你所说，你的妈妈是或曾经是一名演员，这为你进入这个行业并认真对待它铺平了道路。你提到你是独生女。想象一下你和你的父母仍然很亲近。是的。那是，当你开始转型成为一名非常年轻的明星时，
what was that dynamic like with your folks? How much did you rely on them to kind of be there? And how has that relationship changed as you've gotten older? I mean, do you notice it? Yeah, I think when I was younger, my mom, I mean, my mom was my mom, mean my mom was my mom I was under 18 So I was getting invited to these events and stuff and my mom
你和父母的动态是怎样的？你有多依赖他们？随着年龄的增长，这种关系发生了怎样的变化？我的意思是，你注意到了吗？是啊，我想当我年轻的时候，我的妈妈，我的意思是，我的妈妈是我的妈妈，我的意思是我的妈妈是我的妈妈，我未满18岁，所以我被邀请参加这些活动之类的，我的妈妈
From a very early age was like you're gonna walk the carpet Maybe we'll stay for five minutes, but then adult times probably gonna happen and you know It's like the Vanity Fair parties and all that stuff. So she was um She was always very protective of me, but it never really felt like it was suffocating. And she would always say the same thing to me. She said, the moment you stop having fun, stop. It's okay. You know, like you don't need to just kill yourself
从很小的时候就说，你要走红毯，也许我们会待五分钟，但然后成人时间可能会发生，你知道，就像名利场派对之类的。所以她，嗯，她一直非常保护我，但这从来没有让我觉得窒息。她总是对我重复同样的话。她说，当你不再觉得有趣的时候，就停下来。没关系。你知道，就像你不需要自杀一样，
over something if you're not happy. Yeah, because of the hours. Right, and the hours of, people don't understand that the hours and hours and hours of work that it takes to do a TV show, a tour, whatever it is, or a movie, it's just like for a kid. It's hard enough to be a kid. I just think about my own kids and being young teenagers,
如果因为某件事你不开心的话。是啊，因为时间。对，还有时间，人们不明白做电视节目、巡演、无论是什么，或者电影所需要的数小时数小时的工作，这就像对一个孩子来说。做一个孩子已经够难了。我只是想到我自己的孩子，正处于青少年时期，
my older boys that I'm just thinking about. And then the younger ones with the speech problems. Right, I was looking for wizards. Wizards. It's like the idea of them, like Sean, we were over there watching the movie the other night with Archie. Can you imagine Archie, he's 15,
我想到我的大儿子们。然后是那些有语言问题的年幼的孩子。对，我在找《少年魔法师》。《少年魔法师》。就像他们的想法，就像肖恩，那天晚上我们和阿奇（Archie）在那儿看电影。你能想象阿奇，他15岁，
being on the road and working all the time. I think like, no, he wouldn't be able to. He wouldn't be happy, is what Selena's saying. It's tough, right? It's tough. No, it is. And the transition honestly happened around 25 where I didn't feel like I had to impress
一直在路上工作吗？我想，不，他做不到。他不会开心的，这就是赛琳娜所说的。这很难，对吧？这很难。不，确实。而且转型实际上发生在25岁左右，那时我觉得我不必给我的父母留下深刻印象，
my parents more so. But my mom was also really cool because right after Disney she put me in a movie called Spring Breakers. Like she found that movie and it's, you know, very racy. Yeah, very. But it was fun. Yeah, and it wasn't, I mean, I'm sure your mom was not strategic with grabbing that, nor were you, but I'm sure that there was some thought put into it where this would sort of broaden the public's idea about that which you can do and that which is fitting
更多的是。但我的妈妈也很酷，因为在迪士尼之后，她让我演了一部叫《春假》（Spring Breakers）的电影。就像她发现了那部电影，而且，你知道，非常时髦。是啊，非常。但它很有趣。是啊，而且它不是，我的意思是，我相信你的妈妈在抓那个的时候并不具有战略意义，你也不是，但我相信其中有一些想法，这会拓宽公众对你能做什么以及什么适合的想法，
of when they think about you, she can do this, she can do that. And or was it just a part of like, well, this is a little bit closer to who she's starting to become, not somebody who's... My mom was a huge Harmony Corrine fan and she heard there was a script out and so she was interested in it. And the character I play isn't as racy, so I was like 19 when I did it and she just came up to me
当他们想到你时，她可以做这个，她可以做那个。还是这只是像，好吧，这更接近她开始成为的人，而不是某个人……我的妈妈是哈莫尼·科林（Harmony Corrine）的超级粉丝，她听说有一个剧本，所以她对它很感兴趣。而且我演的角色没那么时髦，所以我演的时候大概19岁，她就走到我面前，
and she was, this will make no sense and you're probably gonna think I'm crazy, but just read this. And I read it and I don't know, I gravitated towards the character and then I met Harmony and I was like, oh, game over, he's just really cool. How did your mom have the sense to know good material from bad material or the right material?
她说，这毫无意义，你可能会觉得我疯了，但读读这个。我读了它，我不知道，我被这个角色吸引了，然后我遇到了哈莫尼，我说，哦，游戏结束了，他真的很酷。你的妈妈怎么有这种感觉知道好材料和坏材料，或者正确的材料？
She's really great at that stuff. She found the book 13 Reasons Why, which we turned into a TV show, so she randomly was at a bookstore and she was a young adult and found that and we developed it. She just has really nice taste, you know? And instincts, clearly.
她在那些事情上真的很棒。她发现了书《十三个原因》（13 Reasons Why），我们把它拍成了电视剧，所以她随机在书店里，她是一个年轻人，发现了那个，我们开发了它。她只是有很好的品味，你知道吗？还有直觉，很明显。
Yeah, she's really great. So I like to ask her advice on things. That's great. That's awesome. I love that you guys are so close. Yes. You know, we can cut this part too, but I am fascinated and thankful for how outspoken you are about mental health.
是啊，她真的很棒。所以我喜欢征求她的建议。那太棒了。那太棒了。我喜欢你们这么亲近。是的。你知道，我们可以剪掉这一部分，但我对你谈论心理健康的方式感到着迷和感激。
Because I have somebody very, very close to me who I've had to deal with it, and not deal with it, but just like help with it, and I was happy to help with it. But do you ever? Well, say thank you to him. You've never publicly thanked him well. No, I was gonna say the same thing, all jokes aside, Jason, you dick, I was gonna say, oh no, JK.
因为我有一个非常非常亲近的人，我不得不处理它，不是处理它，而是就像帮助它，我很高兴能帮助它。但你曾经吗？嗯，谢谢他。你从来没有公开感谢过他，威尔。不，我要说同样的话，撇开玩笑不谈，杰森，你这个混蛋，我要说，哦不，开玩笑的。
I was gonna say, I like the way that you're so open and frank about that, about mental health. And I think that it's something that people, luckily talk about more and more, but I think it's really refreshing to hear you talk about it in a way that's very just sort of matter of fact. And I think it's really, I don't know, it shows real maturity and it shows, I think it's really, I don't know, it shows real maturity and it shows,
我要说，我喜欢你对心理健康如此开放和坦率的方式。我认为这是人们，幸运的是谈论得越来越多，但我认为听到你以一种非常实事求是的方式谈论它真的很令人耳目一新。而且我认为这真的，我不知道，它显示了真正的成熟，而且它显示了，我认为这真的，我不知道，它显示了真正的成熟，而且它显示了，
I think it's very brave and I think it helps so many people the way that you talk, honestly, in that way. I really do, it struck me. I think it's really remarkable. It is, it's great because my mom died of Alzheimer's a long time ago. I forget when.
我认为这非常勇敢，而且我认为它帮助了很多人，你谈论的方式，老实说，以那种方式。我真的这么认为，它打动了我。我认为这真的很了不起。是的，这很好，因为我的妈妈很久以前死于阿尔茨海默病。我不记得是什么时候了。
Da da da da da da. And because I, because it was so painful, because it was so painful, I just, me and my sister and my family, because it was so painful, because it was so painful, I just, me and my sister and my family, we would, there's a point where you have to start making it funny. Because you've cried too much about it, so then you cut it with humor, and I have the funniest Alzheimer's stories ever
哒哒哒哒哒哒。因为我，因为这太痛苦了，因为这太痛苦了，我只是，我和我的姐姐和我的家人，因为这太痛苦了，因为这太痛苦了，我只是，我和我的姐姐和我的家人，我们，有一个点你必须开始让它变得有趣。因为你为它哭得太多了，所以你用幽默来切割它，我有过最有趣的阿尔茨海默病故事，
because I lived through it and it was so tragic that my mom, we can cut this too, but my mom would go to the bathroom, she'd go number two in the toilet and I'd walk in there, I'd go, mom, you have to flush the toilet. She goes, I don't know who did that. I don't know who that is. They came in here when I wasn't here,
因为我经历了它，它太悲惨了，以至于我的妈妈，我们可以剪掉这个，但我的妈妈会去洗手间，她在马桶里拉了屎，我走进去，我说，妈妈，你必须冲马桶。她说，我不知道是谁干的。我不知道那是谁。他们在我不在的时候进来了，
they went to the bathroom. We cannot prove that that's mine. We cannot prove that that's mine. And we would laugh because it was past the point. So my question is, have you, me dealing with somebody with no sense. Have I taken a shit and forgotten? No, no, no, no.
他们去了洗手间。我们无法证明那是我的。我们无法证明那是我的。我们会笑，因为它已经过了那个点。所以我的问题是，你，我处理一个没有意识的人。我拉过屎然后忘记了吗？不，不，不，不。
Have you ever? No, have you ever? Like, have you ever just kind of infused humor into the whole situation? Definitely. I also have a few friends that are in comedy and writers and it's just fun. Now me and my family are in a place where we can do that. I don't mind saying the things that I'm walking through and they can be fun and they can be
你曾经吗？不，你曾经吗？就像，你曾经把幽默融入到整个情况中吗？绝对。我也有几个朋友是喜剧演员和作家，这很有趣。现在我和我的家人处于一个我们可以这样做的位置。我不介意说我正在经历的事情，它们可以是有趣的，它们可以是
messy but I've always just. You take the power back. Yeah, just knowing more, I feel better. And it gives so many people, myself included, a little bit more comfort in the reality that I'm not, you know, I'm kind of broken upstairs. We all are. There are as many mental variables in all of us
混乱的，但我一直只是。你夺回了权力。是啊，只是知道更多，我感觉更好。而且它给了很多人，包括我自己，在现实中多了一点安慰，我不是，你知道，我楼上有点坏了。我们都是。我们所有人都有很多心理变量。
as there are physical ones. You can see the physical ones. Someone's taller, someone's shorter, someone's thicker, someone's thinner, someone's got bigger feet, smaller feet. Like, there are equal number of variables in the brain and the fact that we've got medicine, therapeutics, an environment that is tolerant of all of those variables nowadays
就像有生理上的差异一样。你可以看到生理上的差异。有人高，有人矮，有人胖，有人瘦，有人脚大，有人脚小。大脑中也存在同样多的变量，而事实上，我们现在拥有了药物、疗法以及一个对所有这些变量都持包容态度的环境
as opposed to back when our parents were our age. And Jason, on top of that, community. The idea that you're talking about it, it sheds a light and says you're not alone, there's somebody else, and somebody else can relate to that and identify with it. Certainly I know from my own life, and somebody else says I have this,
与我们父母那个年纪时相比。而且杰森，除此之外，还有社区。你谈论这件事的这种想法，它照亮了前方，告诉你你并不孤单，还有别人，别人也能感同身受并产生共鸣。当然，我从我自己的生活中知道，当别人说我有这个时，
and they go, oh, and they talk I have this, and they go, oh. And they talk about their experience, and I go, oh, you have this too. And then we can talk about it in a way that, and that kind of really breaks it wide open. It definitely, it connects you as well. I mean, that's why I released my documentary. It's all based on mental health.
他们会说，哦，然后他们谈论，我有这个，他们会说，哦。他们谈论他们的经历，我说，哦，你也有这个。然后我们可以以一种方式谈论它，那种方式真的把一切都打开了。它绝对也连接了你。我的意思是，这就是我发布纪录片的原因。它完全是基于心理健康的。
Thank you so much. I haven't seen it, I'm so, forgive me, I'm gonna watch it. Oh, no, it's, don't worry. No, pause, we're gonna watch it. It's really kind of sad. No, no, I'm putting it on here. But it ends well.
太感谢了。我还没看过，我很抱歉，我一定会去看的。哦，不，别担心。不，暂停，我们要看它。它真的很让人难过。不，不，我把它放在这儿。但结局很好。
I just, I think that's why I did the documentary. I was terrified before it came out and I had already signed the contract and I was like, damn, I can't go back. But that was a really big moment for me. And then I had people coming up to me not saying like, oh my God, can I have a picture a picture they would say I've dealt with depression or I've done this and then I end up having a connection with people yeah I love that
我只是，我想这就是我拍纪录片的原因。在它出来之前我非常害怕，我已经签了合同，我想，该死，我不能回头了。但那对我来说是一个非常重要的时刻。然后人们走过来不是说，天哪，我可以拍张照吗，他们会说我处理过抑郁症或者我做过这个，然后我最终与人们建立了联系，是的，我喜欢那样
sometimes with all my health stuff like I've had a kidney transplant I have high blood pressure I gosh I have mental mental health and I don't even know. I'm sure I have other problems that I'm not aware of. I love talking about all that. But you can think about a situation and say, why me, why me? And instead, it's given me the gift to say, oh, I know why it's me.
有时因为我所有的健康问题，比如我做过肾移植，我有高血压，天哪，我有心理健康问题，我甚至不知道。我肯定还有其他我不知道的问题。我喜欢谈论所有这些。但你可以思考一种情况并说，为什么是我，为什么是我？相反，它给了我一份礼物，让我说，哦，我知道为什么是我。
I'm there for those people that are going through what I went through and I can say, I hear you and I see you, not just be in and say my life's perfect, but I'm sorry, you know, it's like, well, I can be honest with you. I'm a big believer that the person upstairs, or whomever's upstairs for anybody, doesn't give you anything more than what you can handle.
我为那些经历过我所经历的事情的人在那里，我可以对他们说，我听到了，我看到了，不仅仅是站在那里说我的生活很完美，我很抱歉，你知道，这就像，好吧，我可以对你诚实。我坚信楼上的人，或者对任何人来说楼上是谁，不会给你任何你无法承受的东西。
Yes. And so the fact that you've been given all of these gifts, challenges, and that you're able to go through them so successfully in a public space such that you can give encouragement and support to others is like, I mean, talk about using your years right. We've talked about it on the show before,
是的。所以，你被赋予了所有这些天赋、挑战，并且你能够在公共空间如此成功地度过它们，以至于你可以给别人鼓励和支持，我的意思是，谈谈如何正确利用你的岁月。我们之前在节目中谈过，
about when you get to the end, we're all gonna look back and hope that we used our time correctly. I mean, the first 30 years of your life have been incredibly accomplished spiritually, mentally. Certainly. Yeah, I guess the question really is, Slayne, now what?
关于当你走到终点时，我们都会回顾过去，希望我们正确地利用了我们的时间。我的意思是，你生命的前30年在精神上、心理上都取得了令人难以置信的成就。当然。是的，我想真正的问题是，赛琳娜，现在呢？
Yeah. Yeah. You know, you're fixing your brain, you're fixing the world. Better follow it up. Yeah. I don't know, I think I just, I gravitate towards things I connect to,
是的。是的。你知道，你在修复你的大脑，你在修复世界。最好跟上。是的。我不知道，我想我只是倾向于我能产生共鸣的事物，
and I'm all about authenticity. I can't really force myself to be anything other than who I am, and it's just, you know, luckily worked. It's so good. I'll bet your ability to recognize and attract those who are equally authentic is really keen too. You know, like I was just thinking
我追求的是真实。我真的无法强迫自己成为除我之外的任何人，而且，你知道，幸运的是它奏效了。太好了。我敢说你识别并吸引那些同样真实的人的能力也非常敏锐。你知道，就像我刚才想的那样
when you were talking about the documentary, thinking about Alec Ashishian and his sister, Aline, we both work with. I mean, people like that, like you probably have a great team around you, great friends around you, like all of us as we get older, you have less and less friends, but that's usually by choice. Talk to us about your ability to kind of pick up on people's uniqueness and authenticity or lack thereof. Is that something you always had or has it just gotten sharper? Maybe it has gotten sharper, but ever since I was younger, I had, I like to think I had good discernment with people and I could just sense when I felt that it was being forced
当你谈论纪录片时，想到亚历克·阿什希安和他的妹妹艾琳，我们都和他们一起工作。我的意思是，像那样的人，你周围可能有一个很棒的团队，很棒的朋友，就像我们所有人随着年龄增长，朋友越来越少，但这通常是出于选择。和我们谈谈你捕捉人们的独特性和真实性或缺乏真实性的能力。这是你一直拥有的还是变得更敏锐了？也许它变得更敏锐了，但自从我年轻时，我就有，我喜欢认为我对人有很好的洞察力，我能感觉到什么时候我觉得它是被强迫的
or that there was something they were wanting or whatever. I just could feel that in a lot of people. And I mean, obviously I put some of those people in my life when I was younger and then I later realized, but most of my friends, like I said, they can go from being a writer to one of my friends is a realtor, so I kinda... Is that Richard Ehrlich?
或者他们想要什么之类的。我只是能在很多人身上感觉到这一点。我的意思是，显然我年轻时把其中一些人放进了我的生活中，后来我意识到了，但我的大多数朋友，就像我说的，他们可以从作家变成我的朋友之一是房地产经纪人，所以我有点……那是理查德·埃利希吗？
I kinda just... It's not Richard Ehrlich, is it? No. Yeah, well, it's having people skills, right? And I wonder if you're like me, that's part of what has always attracted me to being an actor, is because I'm just fascinated with people and I really enjoy kind of reading people
我有点只是……不是理查德·埃利希，是吗？不。是的，好吧，这是拥有人际交往能力，对吧？我想知道你是否像我一样，这就是一直吸引我成为演员的部分原因，因为我只是对人着迷，我真的很喜欢阅读人们
and seeing is this person a match for me or not. And I just wonder what that is. Also it's just staying curious, right? The moment you stop being curious, then like Jason just said, you become one of those dummies. Yeah, I know. I love life and I love people and I find it really fun. Do you find that, which do you find
看看这个人是否适合我。我只是想知道那是什么。这也是保持好奇心，对吧？当你停止好奇的那一刻，就像杰森刚才说的，你就变成了那些傻瓜之一。是的，我知道。我热爱生活，我热爱人们，我觉得这真的很有趣。你觉得，你觉得哪一个
is more cathartic for you, more sort of a lane to explore and enjoy parts of you? Is it with playing different characters or being a songwriter? I think it's a little bit of both. I wrote this ballad called Lose You to Love Me and that was probably the most personal song I'd ever released about something that was on everyone's mind for some reason.
对你来说更具宣泄性，更像是一条探索和享受你部分自我的途径？是扮演不同的角色还是成为一名词曲作者？我想两者都有。我写了这首名为《Lose You to Love Me》的民谣，那可能是我发布过的最私人的歌曲，关于某种原因每个人都在想的事情。
And then in acting, I feel like I have these moments in my life that have happened and I'm able to use that and it actually feels great. And it feels, you know, like after a good cry or something, it's like a good feeling. And... Is there something that you... I mean, this is going to be one of the dumbest questions you've ever gotten. Is there something with every single thing that you've done where you're just like, you know what I've never done? I need to do that before.
而在表演中，我觉得我生命中发生了这些时刻，我能够利用它，这实际上感觉很棒。而且感觉，你知道，就像大哭一场之后，这是一种很好的感觉。而且……有什么是你……我的意思是，这将是你收到过的最愚蠢的问题之一。在你做过的每一件事中，有没有什么让你觉得，你知道吗，我从来没做过？我需要在之前做那个。
Oh yeah. I don't think I even began like in a lot of areas. Like I'm not necessarily cosmetics and stuff, but like I've said many times with you guys, I think acting, like I don't think I've been able to even touch the surface of what I know that I'm capable of doing. And I'm very selective or else I'd be in all of the movies that I get offered. And I just fight for my roles and I'm always auditioning.
哦，是的。我不认为我在很多领域甚至开始了。就像我不一定是化妆品之类的，但就像我跟你们说过很多次一样，我认为表演，我不认为我甚至能够触及我知道我有能力做的事情的表面。而且我非常挑剔，否则我会出演所有提供给我的电影。我只是为我的角色而战，我一直在试镜。
So I like to earn it. Yeah, good, that's great. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Something I've sort of really gotten more and more passionate about is not playing characters as much as just playing somebody that doesn't Force me to to do a lot of acting and play a character I kind of like to be the audience and a lot of that comes from my desire to try to be as not full of
所以我喜欢赢得它。是的，很好，那太棒了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。我真正变得越来越热衷的事情不是扮演角色，而是扮演一个不需要强迫我做很多表演和扮演一个角色的人，我有点喜欢成为观众，这很大程度上源于我试图尽可能不充满
Shit as possible in my life and and not be fake and phony and pretending to be other people. So I really like Trying to be as authentic as I can. Do you have a similar sort of battle when you think about acting? Because you're so good about being really you and being in your skin and being honest. Does that run counter to the whole thing that we try to do as actors? Kind of. But I just finished this movie, this Jacquardillard film, and it's all in Spanish and it's a musical, and it was one of the most challenging things that I had done.
废话，在我的生活中，不虚伪、不假装成别人。所以我真的很喜欢尝试尽可能真实。当你想到表演时，你是否有类似的战斗？因为你非常擅长做真实的自己，待在自己的皮肤里并保持诚实。这是否与我们作为演员试图做的整件事背道而驰？有点。但我刚拍完这部电影，这部雅克·欧迪亚的电影，全是西班牙语，是一部音乐剧，这是我做过的最具挑战性的事情之一。
Wow, wow, that's cool. But it's really, what's it called? Emilia Perez, I think that will come out next year. But it's so good if you just said none of your business. I know. None of your business. I'm excited for that because there's, for example, there's the scene where I'm being left, I'm not for that because there's, for example, there's the scene where I'm being
哇，哇，那太酷了。但它真的，它叫什么名字？《艾米莉亚·佩雷斯》，我想明年会出来。但如果你刚才说不关你的事，那就太好了。我知道。不关你的事。我很期待那个，因为有，例如，有我被抛弃的场景，我不是为了那个，因为有，例如，有我被
left and not giving anything away. And I remember I channeled the moment when I had to go to rehab for the first time and leaving and I remember I told my co-star that's what I was feeling in the moment. And I just felt like it was getting that out when I remembered that first moment and being terrified. That's what I was feeling in the moment. And I just felt like it was getting that out when I remembered that first moment and being terrified. So it felt really cathartic. Speaking of that, have you ever wanted to go to the Broadway or do live theater? I'm not sure I'm there yet, because I think I'd still be a little nervous.
抛弃的场景，没有透露任何东西。我记得我引导了当我第一次不得不去康复中心时的那一刻，离开时，我记得我告诉我的联合主演，这就是我当时的感觉。我只是觉得当我记得那一刻并感到恐惧时，把它发泄出来。这就是我当时的感觉。我只是觉得当我记得那一刻并感到恐惧时，把它发泄出来。所以感觉真的很宣泄。说到这个，你有没有想过要去百老汇或做现场戏剧？我不确定我是否准备好了，因为我想我还是会有点紧张。
Oh, really? After touring and stuff, you've already been a stage performer. No, but it's different, because I love when I'm doing my concert, because it's like, oh, these are my peeps. And you feel comfortable. You feel safer, yeah, yeah, for sure. Will you talk more about that, about battling?
哦，真的吗？巡演之后，你已经是舞台表演者了。不，但这不一样，因为我喜欢我做演唱会的时候，因为就像，哦，这些是我的伙伴。你感到舒服。你感到更安全，是的，是的，当然。你会多谈谈那个吗，关于战斗？
Because I get very nervous when I have to speak publicly. Like I can't even give a toast. Really? Yeah, he goes white. Yeah, but I have an enormous amount of confidence when it comes to other things that are going to be made for the public. Like being in front of a camera.
因为当我必须公开演讲时，我会非常紧张。就像我甚至不能敬酒。真的吗？是的，他脸色苍白。是的，但在涉及其他为公众制作的事情时，我有巨大的自信。比如在摄像机前。
Right, for millions of people as opposed to 10 people at a dinner table. are going to be made for the public. Millions of. Like being in front of a camera. Right, for millions of people as opposed to 10 people at a dinner table. So I don't understand that about myself, the difference between having a lot of confidence or zero confidence that are sort of similar things. How do you. Because Jay, because you're so well spoken in life,
对，为数百万人，而不是餐桌旁的10个人。是为公众制作的。数百万。比如在摄像机前。对，为数百万人，而不是餐桌旁的10个人。所以我对自己不理解这一点，拥有很多自信或零自信之间的区别，这些是类似的事情。你怎么做。因为杰，因为你在生活中非常善于言辞，
just I mean clearly in life, that's why it blows my mind that anytime we're at like a dinner party, or like two, three years ago, we are at your birthday dinner party at Richard's house. And I said, let's go around the room and say, how grateful, how much we love Jason, and I'll start. And I got up and I gave this little speech, and it got to Jason, and you were like, I'm out. I don't want any part of this.
只是我的意思是显然在生活中，这就是为什么让我震惊的是，任何时候我们在像晚宴上，或者两三年前，我们在理查德家参加你的生日晚宴。我说，让我们绕着房间说，我们有多感激，我们有多爱杰森，我先来。我站起来发表了这个小演讲，轮到杰森了，你说，我退出。我不想参与其中。
It's like, goodbye. But yeah, so how do you manage that? Like what is that switch that flicks for you when you can stand up in front of 100,000 people and give a concert or do a movie or television show that's gonna be for millions of people versus like maybe going out on a date for the first time or doing an interview for a magazine,
就像，再见。但是是的，所以你是怎么处理那个的？就像当你能站在10万人面前举办演唱会或拍摄电影或电视节目，而这些节目将面向数百万人，与比如第一次约会或接受杂志采访相比，那个为你拨动的开关是什么，
or whatever might give you anxiety, do you know what that is, that different thing? Because I'm still trying to figure it out with myself. I think when I was younger, I had a very, very public life, and it wasn't fair in a lot of ways that I got to the point so much so that I was like if I don't talk about what's going on everyone's gonna continue to narrate my life and people are just gonna buy it and I need people
或者任何可能让你焦虑的事情，你知道那是什么吗，那个不同的东西？因为我还在试图弄清楚我自己。我想当我年轻的时候，我有一个非常、非常公开的生活，在很多方面这都不公平，我到了那个地步，以至于我想如果我不谈论正在发生的事情，每个人都会继续叙述我的生活，人们只会买账，我需要人们
to hear from me and I genuinely stopped caring like I don't I don't care like I would be happy to stand up and speak very highly of someone. I'd be happy to do it. Even if I mess up, I'm like, all right, well, that sucked. But I tried. It's fine. So I don't know if I've done it for too long that I just have lost a little bit of that fear. But I still get the butterfly feeling. Yeah, so maybe I just got used to it And I'm kind of like well people are gonna like it or not. Yeah, I have a friend of mine Maria Shriver she you know I've known her for years and years and decades and she I Whenever I would have dinner at her house. She she's the one who forced me to get up and talk like that and it's so I was
听到我的声音，我真的不再在乎了，就像我不，我不在乎，就像我很乐意站起来高度评价某人。我很乐意这样做。即使我搞砸了，我也想，好吧，那很烂。但我试过了。没关系。所以我不知道我是不是做的时间太长了，以至于我失去了一点那种恐惧。但我仍然有蝴蝶的感觉。是的，所以也许我只是习惯了，我有点像，好吧，人们会喜欢它与否。是的，我有一个朋友玛丽亚·施莱弗，你知道我认识她很多年、几十年了，她，每当我在她家吃晚饭时。她，她是那个强迫我站起来说话的人，所以我当时
littered you know, sorry, I was riddled with fear about it. And, but she forced me to do it. She's like, we're gonna go around and stand up and speak how you feel. And I was like, pass. I'm going to the next person. Were you so nervous because you had just littered? Is that what it was?
乱七八糟的，你知道，抱歉，我对此充满了恐惧。但是，她强迫我这样做。她说，我们要绕着圈站起来说出你的感受。我说，跳过。我要去下一个人。你是因为你刚才乱七八糟的所以那么紧张吗？是那样吗？
Yeah. Like, I'm having a tough time following what happened. But, but Jay, Jason. But now that you're saying it, I think for me, it's like I'm afraid of being accused or judged as either being full of shit or being stuck up. I had a real complex about being conceited and stuck up when I was in middle school. Like sixth and seventh grade was really hard for me in school because people, oh, here comes that guy on TV.
是的。就像，我很难跟上发生了什么。但是，但是杰，杰森。但现在你这么说，我想对我来说，就像我害怕被指责或评判为要么是满嘴胡言，要么是傲慢。我在中学时对自负和傲慢有很深的情结。就像六年级和七年级在学校对我来说真的很艰难，因为人们，哦，那个电视上的人来了。
He's stuck up. So I wasn't really, I was shy about being confident because people would think I was stuck up. So then I tried to seem not confident and then maybe that part of me kind of took hold. But what's crazy about that though is, think about it, that's inauthentic. Yeah, exactly.
他很傲慢。所以我并不是真的，我因为自信而害羞，因为人们会认为我很傲慢。所以我试图看起来不自信，然后也许我那部分就占据了主导。但疯狂的是，想想看，那是不真实的。是的，完全正确。
If you think about it, you fell victim to the very thing that you were trying to prevent. I mean that honestly. And when you're thinking about it that much, you put a space between you and people you're trying to connect with, Jay. I really mean it. And if you can break that down and react in real time,
如果你仔细想想，你成了你试图防止的那件事的受害者。我的意思是真的。当你思考那么多时，你在你试图与之建立联系的人和你之间留下了空间，杰。我是认真的。如果你能打破它并实时反应，
then it will never be inauthentic. But the second you start thinking about, you're trying to curate what other people think of you, that's inauthentic. Yeah, and it makes me so nervous because I'm having to manage two things at the very same time. Right, right. Because you're taking care of their feelings before yours.
那么它永远不会是不真实的。但当你开始思考的那一秒，你试图策划别人对你的看法，那是不真实的。是的，这让我很紧张，因为我必须同时处理两件事。对，对。因为你在照顾他们的感受之前先照顾了你的。
Yeah, you're never gonna be able to, I remember somebody saying, what, you can't tell everybody how to treat you or how to look at you. There's nothing you can do about the way people think about you. All you can do is take it. None of your business.
是的，你永远无法，我记得有人说，什么，你不能告诉每个人如何对待你或如何看待你。关于人们对你的看法，你无能为力。你所能做的就是接受它。不关你的事。
Well, yeah, there's that and also, you'll never get to it. Selena, one second. Yeah, that's fine. No, it's okay, I'm enjoying this. I like this conversation. But really, just really quick, it's the same thing that I've carried around
好吧，是的，有那个，而且，你永远不会达到那个程度。赛琳娜，等一下。是的，没关系。不，没关系，我很享受这个。我喜欢这个对话。但真的，很快，这是我一直带着的同样的事情
for so long being gay, is like, I've constantly my entire life, I just came out, my entire life, I spent taking care of other people's feelings and putting mine second, and then you have to reach a point where Selena's saying, we're like, I can't, I'm exhausted by taking care of other people's feelings and putting mine second. And then you have to reach a point where Selena is saying, we're like, I can't, I'm exhausted. But why did you do that for being gay?
这么久以来作为同性恋，就像，我一直我整个人生，我刚刚出柜，我整个人生，我花在照顾别人的感受上，把我的放在第二位，然后你必须达到一个赛琳娜所说的点，我们就像，我不能，我因为照顾别人的感受而精疲力竭，把我的放在第二位。然后你必须达到一个赛琳娜所说的点，我们就像，我不能，我精疲力竭。但你为什么因为是同性恋而那样做？
With regards to you being gay, is that what you mean? Yeah, yeah. Like if I enter a room, even today, I still have a little bit left over, but for the most part I don't care. It's like I have to check, like I'm so used to, it's in my blood now, to check how people think about me entering a room. Are they thinking about my being gay or not?
关于你是同性恋，你是这个意思吗？是的，是的。就像如果我进入一个房间，即使是今天，我仍然有一点残留，但在大多数情况下我不在乎。就像我必须检查，就像我习惯了，它现在在我的血液里，去检查人们对我进入房间的看法。他们是在想我是同性恋还是不是？
I used to do this when I was younger. I remember I was doing an interview and I sat down and there was probably 14 people behind the camera and I think I was maybe 21. I the camera, and I think I was maybe 21, and I started to sweat, and I ran away, and I started crying. Because this is what I was thinking. I was like, these people probably think I sound stupid.
我年轻时经常这样做。我记得我在接受采访，我坐下来，摄像机后面可能有14个人，我想我当时可能21岁。我摄像机，我想我当时可能21岁，我开始出汗，我跑开了，我开始哭。因为这就是我在想的。我在想，这些人可能认为我听起来很蠢。
They're going to go home and tell their partners or friends about how much of an idiot I am, and I feel like a horrible interviewer. It used to kill me. Yes, it would kill me. Really? A panic attack, yeah. I've had that, and I couldn't, I was stuck there.
他们会回家告诉他们的伴侣或朋友我是个多么白痴的人，我觉得自己是个糟糕的采访者。它曾经折磨我。是的，它会折磨我。真的吗？恐慌发作，是的。我有过那个，我不能，我被困在那里了。
And it just becomes exponentially more horrific and terrifying because now you're convinced, now they can see that I'm having a panic attack. Now it gets even worse. It's like, oh yeah, yeah. And so. You have that too, huh? I mean, I still fall back into it,
它变得呈指数级更加可怕和恐怖，因为现在你确信，现在他们能看到我正在恐慌发作。现在情况变得更糟了。就像，哦，是的，是的。所以。你也有那个，嗯？我的意思是，我仍然会陷入其中，
but I've caught here and there, but for the most part I'm like. I really mean this, I'm sure there'll be a lot of listeners like shut the fuck up, really this is new to me, I don't understand it in that way. Everybody's wired differently. It's a form of parenting. Like when I got this, you know, when I got this.
但我偶尔会抓住它，但在大多数情况下我像。我是认真的，我相信会有很多听众说闭嘴，真的这对我是新的，我不以那种方式理解它。每个人都有不同的连接方式。这是一种育儿方式。就像当我得到这个，你知道，当我得到这个。
And I was so, obviously. He's holding up just some sort of, just plain white faceless body. And I thought, okay, thank you everybody. But I feel like the older I get, the closer I get to our favorite term, sexy indifference. Or rather, better said,, sexy indifference, or rather, better said, a healthy indifference,
我非常，显然。他举起某种，只是一个普通的白色无脸身体。我想，好吧，谢谢大家。但我觉得我越老，我就越接近我们最喜欢的词，性感冷漠。或者更确切地说，性感冷漠，或者更确切地说，一种健康的冷漠，
where you do care what people think, but you're not obsessed by it and you're not pulled around by it. I will challenge you on that because we're doing it right now today. That is also put on. It's not real, because if you have to think about the sexy indifference,
你确实在乎人们的想法，但你并没有被它困扰，你也没有被它牵着鼻子走。我会对此挑战你，因为我们今天就在做这件事。那也是装出来的。它不是真实的，因为如果你必须考虑性感冷漠，
then it's not organic. Right. You know what I mean? I'm trying to get to that place of honest and healthy indifference where it's just right sized. Where you do care about people, you don't wanna be rude, you wanna be sensitive to people. You just wanna seem desperate. The freedom is when you don't even have to recognize
那么它就不是有机的。对。你知道我的意思吗？我正试图达到那种诚实和健康的冷漠，它恰到好处。你确实在乎人们，你不想粗鲁，你想对人们敏感。你只是不想看起来绝望。自由在于当你甚至不需要承认
that you do have indifference, that you're just living. That's the freedom. Otherwise, you're shackled by the idea of it. It still lives there as an idea. I think. But it's also what we do for a living, right? It's part of our job to be aware of what people think and kind of manipulate that.
你确实有冷漠，你只是在生活。那就是自由。否则，你被它的想法束缚住了。它仍然作为一个想法存在。我想。但这也是我们谋生的方式，对吧？意识到人们的想法并操纵它是我们工作的一部分。
And like, we're professional liars, you know? And so it was a little bit of a head screw for me, obviously still is, when I was a kid. When you're trying to figure out who you are and who you're becoming, you're training yourself how to fake to be somebody else. It's kind of a little bit of a blender. It's very weird. Do you still think about that, Selena?
而且，我们是职业骗子，你知道吗？所以当我还是个孩子的时候，这对我来说有点头晕，显然现在仍然是。当你试图弄清楚你是谁以及你正在成为谁时，你正在训练自己如何假装成别人。这有点像搅拌机。这非常奇怪。你还在想那个吗，赛琳娜？
Absolutely. I remember I was talking about this with someone and there was a study that said, the moment you get famous at a certain age, you end up stuck in that area for a while because it's- Emotionally. Yes, because it stunts, you're dealing with things that no child
绝对。我记得我和某人谈论过这个，有一项研究说，当你在这个特定年龄出名时，你最终会卡在那个区域一段时间，因为它是——情感上。是的，因为它阻碍了，你正在处理没有孩子
should be dealing with and criticizing my body or something weird, like it just, it felt, ugh, it just doesn't feel good. You can't grow privately like most people do. Yeah, so I mean I don't regret my life, but there's a huge part of me that's like, yeah, I wonder what that would have been like to just be me for a second. So, but this, I'm assuming that you've got millions,
应该处理的事情，批评我的身体或一些奇怪的事情，就像它只是，呃，它只是感觉不好。你不能像大多数人那样私下成长。是的，所以我的意思是我不后悔我的生活，但有很大一部分我像，是的，我想知道如果只是做一秒钟的我会是什么样子。所以，但这个，我假设你有数百万，
literally millions of people that admire you more than any of us could probably imagine because of how brave you are with how honest you are. And that is not going to go away, thank God. I mean, you're a role model whether you like it or not. Until I run away from everything. No, no, you're not gonna go, wherever you go you're gonna be there.
字面上的数百万钦佩你的人，比我们任何人能想象的都要多，因为你对自己的诚实是多么勇敢。而且那不会消失，感谢上帝。我的意思是，无论你是否喜欢，你都是榜样。直到我从一切中逃跑。不，不，你不会走的，无论你去哪里你都会在那里。
No, don't take away her out until you run away, if you want. I've run away. But I now get it though, Jay, I wanna say, you just mentioned that, I wanna say that I now get it when I sort of earlier, flippantly when we first started talking about how many millions of followers you have, I now understand, I get it now,
不，不要带走她的出路，直到你逃跑，如果你想的话。我逃跑了。但我现在明白了，杰，我想说，你刚才提到了，我想说我现在明白了，当我早些时候，当我们刚开始谈论你有多少百万粉丝时，我轻率地，我现在明白了，我现在明白了，
your relationship with that number, with those numbers of people is tricky. And I sort of have a little bit more of an understanding, I really mean that, maybe I'm a slow learner. But I. No, no, it's weird, it's such a bizarre thing. have a little bit more of an understanding. and it's like, I don't need this information. I just want to post a photo and let it be for my fans and move on.
你与那个数字，与那些人数的关系很棘手。我稍微多了一点理解，我是认真的，也许我是一个慢学习者。但我。不，不，这很奇怪，这是一件如此离奇的事情。稍微多了一点理解。就像，我不需要这些信息。我只是想发一张照片，让它成为我的粉丝，然后继续前进。
And they are definitely attracted to all the things that are very special about you and not to take away from any of that, but I think it is also very indicative of how common it is for people around the world to be not perfect. And I think they really are comforted by how you are so honest about how not perfect you are. And I think that's just a real gift
他们绝对被你身上所有非常特别的东西所吸引，而不是为了带走任何东西，但我认为这也非常表明世界各地的人们不完美是多么普遍。而且我认为他们真的被你对你不完美程度的诚实所安慰。而且我认为这真的是一份礼物
that you give to people. And myself included, I thank you for that. I cannot believe we're already past an hour. This is literally the fastest interview. Yeah, I'm stunned. We're not an hour right now, but it is pretty crazy. Yeah. I feel like we're just going to the surface.
你给人们的。包括我自己，我为此感谢你。我不敢相信我们已经过了一个小时。这真的是最快的采访。是的，我惊呆了。我们现在还没到一个小时，但这真的很疯狂。是的。我觉得我们只是触及了表面。
I'm like, guys, let's go have brunch. I wanna let you go, but I know we have probably a couple more questions. Sean, go. Yes, no, I just wanna know, Only Murders, I love the show, I love you in it, I love Stephen Mardi. How did it come about? What was it like when you started? Did you just love Murders? How you got into Murders, I love the show, I love you in it, I love Stephen Mardi. How did it come about, what was it like when you started? Did you just love Murders, was that how you got into it?
我像，伙计们，我们去吃早午餐吧。我想让你走，但我知道我们可能还有几个问题。肖恩，去吧。是的，不，我只是想知道，《大楼里只有谋杀案》，我喜欢这个节目，我喜欢你在里面的表现，我喜欢史蒂芬·马丁。它是怎么来的？你开始的时候是什么感觉？你只是喜欢谋杀案吗？你是怎么进入谋杀案的，我喜欢这个节目，我喜欢你在里面的表现，我喜欢史蒂芬·马丁。它是怎么来的，你开始的时候是什么感觉？你只是喜欢谋杀案吗，那是你进入它的方式吗？
To be honest, yes, and I like very dark documentaries sometimes, so I tend to lean into those, especially scary stuff, mentally. And John Hoffman is one of my very, very close friends. But no, it actually happened because, well, Steve's original idea was that it was going to be like mentally. Yeah. And John Hoffman is one of my very, very close friends of mine. I love him. So, but no, it actually happened because, well, Steve's original idea was that it was going to be three men. And then John Hoffman suggested that they hired...
老实说，是的，我有时喜欢非常黑暗的纪录片，所以我倾向于倾向于那些，尤其是可怕的东西，精神上的。约翰·霍夫曼是我非常、非常亲密的朋友之一。但没有，它实际上发生是因为，好吧，史蒂夫最初的想法是它将是像精神上的。是的。约翰·霍夫曼是我非常、非常亲密的朋友之一。我爱他。所以，但没有，它实际上发生是因为，好吧，史蒂夫最初的想法是它将是三个男人。然后约翰·霍夫曼建议他们雇佣……
He created the show. Yes, who created the show. He said, I think it would be really cool if we added like a younger character, maybe a female. We added like a younger character, maybe a female, and Steve liked the idea. And I guess this was really a gift because they had me in mind. And I remember thinking, I'm like, okay, well, what does this mean?
他创作了这个节目。是的，谁创作了这个节目。他说，我觉得如果我们增加一个像更年轻的角色，也许是一个女性，会很酷。我们增加一个像更年轻的角色，也许是一个女性，史蒂夫喜欢这个想法。我想这真的是一份礼物，因为他们想到了我。我记得我在想，我像，好吧，这意味着什么？
And then I had FaceTime with all of them, with Steve, Marty, and John, and producers. And I was like, oh, I just have to do this because simply the people are amazing. And then the success of it after. It's a good hang. Yeah, and then the success after was just
然后我和他们所有人，和史蒂夫、马丁、约翰以及制片人进行了FaceTime。我当时想，哦，我必须做这个，因为简单地说，人们太棒了。然后之后的成功。这是一个很好的聚会。是的，之后的成功只是
such a surprise and we just were happy to do it. Only murders in the building, never manslaughter. Never manslaughter. Never manslaughter, just murders. Okay, I'm fine, I'm allowed to ask. Yes you are. And that is in its fourth year or fifth year? Coming up on the fifth.
一个惊喜，我们只是很高兴能做它。《大楼里只有谋杀案》，从不过失杀人。从不过失杀人。从不过失杀人，只有谋杀。好吧，我很好，我被允许问。是的，你是。那是它的第四年还是第五年？即将进入第五年。
We just got renewed for season four. Season four. And we may have to cut this, but John, I asked John, I was like, how many more seasons? And he goes, well I asked Steve and Steve said forever. I know, he does. My favorite thing about Steve, and he knows that why ask Steve? And Steve said forever. I know he does. My favorite thing about Steve, and he knows that I've said this before,
我们刚刚续订了第四季。第四季。我们可能不得不剪掉这个，但约翰，我问约翰，我像，还有多少季？他说，好吧，我问了史蒂夫，史蒂夫说永远。我知道，他会的。我最喜欢史蒂夫的一点，他知道为什么问史蒂夫？史蒂夫说永远。我知道他会的。我最喜欢史蒂夫的一点，他知道我之前说过这个，
but my favorite thing is Steve will be like, I've gotta get home. I gotta get home, I gotta go. I'm too old for this. And then I'll be like, well, I go, Steve, how many seasons do we do? He's like, oh, I don't wanna stop. We're gonna keep going.
但我最喜欢的一点是史蒂夫会说，我得回家了。我得回家，我得走了。我太老了，做不了这个。然后我会说，好吧，我说，史蒂夫，我们做多少季？他说，哦，我不想停下来。我们要继续下去。
And I'm like, what? He's just like. You've got to get home. Exactly, but you need to be home. So sometimes I'll be like, I'll carry the load because I get. It is the greatest trio, but as has been said before, one of the oddest trios ever. And it's just awesome.
然后我像，什么？他只是像。你得回家。没错，但你需要回家。所以有时我会像，我会承担重担，因为我得到。这是最伟大的三人组，但正如之前所说，有史以来最奇怪的三人组之一。而且这太棒了。
It's awesome. It's infectious. Thank you. Awesome. Yeah. Thank you. Well, Selena, this has been great. Thank you, honey, for being here. Yeah, of course.
这太棒了。它具有传染性。谢谢。太棒了。是的。谢谢。好吧，赛琳娜，这太棒了。谢谢你，亲爱的，来到这里。是的，当然。
I just wanted to tell you, Jason, really quick. Yes, ma'am? I am gonna send your wife, Amanda, and your girls some of my new collection from Rare Beauty. Oh, you sweet thing. And like a whole little box, because I would love to see what they thought. They're enormous fans of yours, as Amanda my wife so I can I want to send you that
我只是想告诉你，杰森，很快。是的，女士？我要给你的妻子阿曼达和你的女儿们寄一些我从Rare Beauty来的新系列。哦，你这个贴心的人。就像一个完整的小盒子，因为我很想看看她们怎么想。她们是你的忠实粉丝，就像我的妻子阿曼达一样，所以我可以，我想寄给你那个
because this is gonna be this is gonna be one of the biggest collections that I've released and I'm beyond stoked for it I know it's it's little things like that that make me happy because yeah but it's not a little thing. It's really impressive what you've done with this. This company is potentially, if it's not already, bigger than anything you've done in music or in film or television. Absolutely. Or in social media.
因为这将是，这将是我发布过的最大的系列之一，我对此感到无比兴奋，我知道，正是这些小事让我快乐，因为是的，但这并不是一件小事。你用这个做的事情真的很令人印象深刻。这家公司可能，如果还不是的话，比你在音乐、电影或电视中做过的任何事情都要大。绝对。或者在社交媒体上。
I mean, it's an enormous company. And you really should be proud of that. But I think it's good products, and we also just try not to be everything else. You know, like I'm not huge on promoting like crazy, you know, makeup, I love makeup, but I want my line to represent yourself and to have fun with it.
我的意思是，这是一家巨大的公司。你真的应该为此感到自豪。但我认为这是好的产品，而且我们也只是尽量不成为其他一切。你知道，就像我不热衷于疯狂地推广，你知道，化妆，我喜欢化妆，但我希望我的系列代表你自己，并从中获得乐趣。
It seems very consistent with you and what you represent. Yeah, well, might I say your skin is flawless. Oh my goodness, well, thank you. She takes off her glasses, she goes cross-eyed. She did a Richard Ehrlich earlier. What is it? Say, it's where? Say, he's a little bit confused,
这似乎与你和你所代表的一切非常一致。是的，好吧，我可以评价你的皮肤是无瑕的吗。哦，天哪，好吧，谢谢。她摘下眼镜，她变成了斗鸡眼。她早些时候做了一个理查德·埃利希。是什么？说，它在哪里？说，他有点困惑，
and then that kid look at that beautiful. No, she's gonna let her say it's where. Say it, ready and action. No, it's where? I swear. Oh my God, that's good. That's really's where. Say it, ready and action. No, I swear. I swear. Oh my God, that's good. That's really good. You look just like Richard Ehrlich.
然后那个孩子看着那个美丽的。不，她会让她说它在哪里。说出来，准备好了，开始。不，它在哪里？我发誓。哦，天哪，那太好了。那真的是在哪里。说出来，准备好了，开始。不，我发誓。我发誓。哦，天哪，那太好了。那真的很好。你看上去就像理查德·埃利希。
Great. Celina, you're the greatest. Thank you so much for doing this. This was a big, big get for us. It's so awesome to finally meet you too. I am so happy and hopefully I'll get to meet you all in person. I'm sure I'll run into you, Jason. I'm just, I'm a big fan of all of you
太棒了。赛琳娜，你是最棒的。非常感谢你做这个。这对我们来说是一个很大、很大的收获。终于见到你也很棒。我太高兴了，希望我能亲自见到你们所有人。我相信我会遇到你的，杰森。我只是，我是你们所有人的忠实粉丝
and I've really been wanting to do this for a while. I'm sure you know, Jason. So this has been really great. Thank you. Yeah, thank you for doing it. All right, have a great, great rest of the day and thanks for talking with us. All right, bye guys.
而且我真的想做这个有一段时间了。我相信你知道，杰森。所以这真的很棒。谢谢。是的，谢谢你做这个。好吧，祝你们余下的一天过得愉快，谢谢和我们交谈。好吧，再见，伙计们。
Bye, Selena, thank you. You see, now, guys, there's a nice person. You guys have asked me multiple times. You say to me, you say, Jason, how do I get, how can I become nice? How can I become nicer, you know, and be pleasant? Have success, isn't that your theory? Have success and then you're allowed to be nice.
再见，赛琳娜，谢谢。你看，现在，伙计们，有一个好人。你们多次问过我。你们对我说，你们说，杰森，我怎么才能，我怎么才能变得好？我怎么才能变得更好，你知道，并且令人愉快？获得成功，这不是你的理论吗？获得成功，然后你就可以变得好了。
Well, but then after that, try to be, not before, not before, because then they're gonna be accused of, somebody as kind and as gentle as loving as she is. What is that? Will's holding up a fake award. This is my dressing room, I don't know. It looks like an award. It looks like an Oscar. Yeah, she's really terrific.
好吧，但在那之后，试着变得，而不是之前，不是之前，因为那样他们会被指责，像她一样善良、温柔、充满爱心的人。那是什么？威尔举起一个假奖杯。这是我的更衣室，我不知道。它看起来像一个奖项。它看起来像奥斯卡。是的，她真的很棒。
Did you learn anything, you guys? I did, I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah, I's really terrific. What did you both, did you learn anything, you guys? I did, I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah, I think you are. Well, A, lazy, because she's just so, it seems like everything she does, she's successful at. Even mental health. Right. She's successful at that.
你们学到了什么吗，伙计们？我学到了，我觉得我很懒。是的，她真的很棒。你们两个，你们学到了什么吗，伙计们？我学到了，我觉得我很懒。是的，我想你是。好吧，A，懒，因为她只是那么，看起来她做的每一件事，她都很成功。即使是心理健康。对。她在那个方面很成功。
I know, right? Because she's not running from it, she's going right through it. She's just, it's pretty remarkable. And she's such a, talked about, we were talking, authenticity was a central theme today, and she's so authentic. Yeah, she's like a superhero.
我知道，对吧？因为她没有逃避它，她正直接穿过它。她只是，这非常了不起。而且她是一个，谈论过，我们正在谈论，真实性是今天的一个中心主题，而且她非常真实。是的，她就像一个超级英雄。
She really doesn't, like she said, she just does what she loves to do. Everybody's welcome to come or don't come. Like, you know what's funny, I was gonna say, she said that she didn't care, but it's almost like she, it's not that she doesn't care, it feels like she just, what she cares about is just being herself and being honest about it.
她真的没有，就像她说的那样，她只是做她喜欢做的事情。欢迎每个人来或不来。就像，你知道什么很有趣，我本来想说，她说她不在乎，但这几乎就像她，并不是她不在乎，感觉她只是，她在乎的是只是做她自己并对此保持诚实。
Right, she turned that care internal. She's taking care of number one, which for me always lets me be a better person to the people around me. Sometimes I over-index in the selfishness, but I'm trying to get the right balance. Yeah. Yeah. No, sorry.
对，她把那种关心转向了内部。她在照顾第一位，这对我来说总是让我成为周围人更好的人。有时我在自私方面过度索引，但我正在努力获得正确的平衡。是的。是的。不，抱歉。
No. Did you? Still rolling. Let's get one more of those, Will. A little more convincing. Oh, no, Jason. I was, by the way, I held up on so many because it was such, so many things I wanted to throw in
不。你学到了吗？还在录。让我们再来一个，威尔。更有说服力一点。哦，不，杰森。我当时，顺便说一句，我忍住了很多，因为它是如此，有很多我想加入的事情
and I didn't because it was just out of respect. Oh, so you've got some unused jokes you'd like to workshop real quick? I mean, no, no, no, no. There was one at the end certainly that I wanted to say. Yeah, let's hear it. Which is, don't worry, I'll carry the load, Steve. And I was like, Sean, how many times?
但我没有，因为这只是出于尊重。哦，所以你有一些没用过的笑话想快速研讨一下？我的意思是，不，不，不，不。最后确实有一个我想说的。是的，让我们听听。那就是，别担心，我会承担重担，史蒂夫。我当时想，肖恩，多少次？
Okay, so. So you. Do you want to know. It's Steve, right? It's Steve, right? It's Steve. Do you want to know though, speaking about Archie, your son, you know, one time.
好吧，所以。所以你。你想知道吗。是史蒂夫，对吧？是史蒂夫，对吧？是史蒂夫。你想知道吗，说到阿奇，你的儿子，你知道，有一次。
Uh-oh, here we go, this is a your son, you know, one time outside. No, no, this is outside once I had a wizard crawl up my pants. Did you really? Yeah. Truly? Truly, a lizard? A wizard.
哦哦，我们要开始了，这是你的儿子，你知道，有一次在外面。不，不，这是在外面，有一次我有一只蜥蜴爬进我的裤子里。你真的吗？是的。真的？真的，一只蜥蜴？一只巫师。
And how hard did it get up before it pulled a quick 180 and said, no, thank you. No, that's such a funny thing, wizard. You could use it for so many things. Oh, you know what? Okay. So part of my, what is it called? The Gay Tray that Jason calls it.
在它快速转了180度并说，不，谢谢之前，它爬得有多高？不，那是一件如此有趣的事情，巫师。你可以把它用于很多事情。哦，你知道吗？好吧。所以我的部分，它叫什么？杰森称之为同性恋托盘。
Oh yeah, no, no, no, what? It wasn't this one. Yeah, no, the Gay Tray. It's an Invisalign thing. I didn't know you had it in today. Yeah, so I have it in every day, and then, but I can whiten my teeth. But my dentist, three days ago said,
哦是的，不，不，不，什么？不是这个。是的，不，同性恋托盘。这是一个隐形矫治器。我不知道你今天戴着它。是的，所以我每天都戴着它，然后，但我可以美白我的牙齿。但我的牙医，三天前说，
you can hear some teeth whitening stuff you can put in the Invisalign trays. And, but you don't have to put them in the back where the... By Cuspids! Are. By. Smart. Smart. Smart. Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids!
你可以听到一些牙齿美白的东西，你可以放进隐形矫治器托盘里。但是，你不必把它们放在后面，那里……在尖牙旁边！是。在。聪明。聪明。聪明。再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！
Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids!
再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！
Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! Bye Cuspids! handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！再见尖牙！由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科手工制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。